the voting session lasted nearly 12
hours an entire day to review evidence
gathered by the brazilian senate
committee which spent the past six
months investigating the government's
handling of the pandemic
in the end seven of the eleven committee
members approved the final report
holding 80 people responsible for the
600 thousand people who've died of kovid
19 in brazil
but the report lays most of the blame on
president jair bolsonaro who's
downplayed the virus and pushed to
curtail lockdown measures the senate
recommends he be charged with nine
crimes among them crimes against
humanity
bolsonaro is accused of letting covid19
spread throughout brazil in a failed
attempt to achieve herd immunity through
infection and somehow protect the
economy
brazil has the world's second largest
death toll after the united states
according to the report a third of those
lives could have been saved had the
president taken the pandemic seriously
and acted sooner
instead he called it a little flu
encouraged mass gatherings spent public
resources pushing unproven treatments
delayed the vaccination campaign and
spoke out against vaccines
that's despite the president himself
testing positive for covid19
just last week bolsonaro continued
spreading misinformation on social media
facebook and youtube took down a video
in which he falsely claimed that kovid
19 vaccines were linked to developing
aids senator henron carlieros who wrote
the report was clear in his assessment
of the president's role this is serial
killer the president is a serial killer
who has a death fixation and continues
to repeat everything that has been said
in the past
now with this declaration that the
vaccine can infect people with aids
clearly demonstrates he has no respect
for brazilian lives
after approving the report the committee
asked brazil's supreme court to ban
bolsonaro from using social media but
the president's supporters say the
committee has its own political agenda
and its main goal is to defeat bolsonaro
in next year's presidential elections
the report will now be submitted to
brazil's attorney general who has 30
days to respond it's highly unlikely
that most charges will be brought before
next year's presidential elections
but the senate committee says its
investigation has already had an impact
it has cast a spotlight on the
government's wrongdoings and raised
public awareness
monika yanakiv al-jazeera